والى جانبي ازمه الطاقه التي اثرت على كل
دول العالم الركود والتضخم يعبثان
بالاقتصاد العالمي ويدفعان دول عديده الى
اتخاذ قرارات صعبه من بين هذه هي الدول
بريطانيا التي تعيش ازمه تضخم حقيقيه
دفعتها الى تبني سياسه التقشف فالمملكه
المتحده سجلت نسبه تضخم القياسيه خلال سنه
الماضيه تجاوزت 10% وهي الاعلى منذ اربعه
عقود كما ارتفعت اسعار المواد الغذائيه
بمعدل وصل الى 11% كلها عوامل ادت الى
انخفاض قيمه الاجور وتدني مستوى المعيشه
ما اسفر عن موجه احتجاجات واضرابات غير
مسبوقه اجتاحت البلاد خلال شهر ديسمبر
الموت
الحكومه البريطانيه رات اذا في سياسه
التقشف فوق نجاه لمواجهه هذه الازمه
المرشحه الى الاستمرار خلال هذه السنه
الجديده الحكومه قررت خفض الانفاق بما
يعادل 55 مليار جنيه استرليني في السنه
كما اقررت ضرائب استثنائيه من بينها ضريبه
على ارباح شركه الطاقه تصل الى 35 بالمئه
وتمتد حتى العام 2018 كما فرضت ضريبه
قاسيه على منتجين الكهرباء نسبتها 45%
لكن من بين القرارات المثيره للجدل التي
اتخذتها الحكومه البريطانيه تقليص الدعم
الموجه لقطاعات الفنون والثقافه من 36
مليون جنيه استرليني الى 19 مليون على ان
تحول قيمه تلك التخفيضات لدعم العلوم
الاساسيه والتكنولوجيا والهندسه
[موسيقى]